الاشهر الاخيره كانت في الحمل بالمره ما
كانش لا رعايه ولا صحه وكان امراض الامراض
كانت بشكل مش طبيعي للكبار وللصغار كانت
ما كانتش متوفره بالمره يعني فش لا ميه
صحيه ولا اكل زي
الناس الاطفال كانوا بالمره جعانين كثير
خلال الاشهر الاخيره في الميه كانت ل
الحامل المفروض تشرب ميه صح
واحنا ما كناش نشربها الميه الصحيه خلال
الشهر الاخير الشهر التاسع هو كان اكتئاب
بالمره كان على وفاه جوزي الله يرحمه
والواحده الا ما تحتاج جوزها جنبها انا
تميت استنى ليخلص شهر يعني ما كانش في
مجال اني اروح على المستشفى ما كانش في
اسعاف قادر تجيني اني انا اروح اولد يعني
فخلص شهري وانا معيش وجع من الخوف ومن
الرعب رحت على كمال عدوان مشي من معسكر
جبالي لكمال عدوان مشي تحت القصف وع الردم
ووجع كنت كثير تعبانه يعني ايام ما بحبش
اتذكرها